ça n'est pas vrai qu'une avance d'abord
je voudrais dire que ça n'est en aucun
cas un dérapage
ce sont des déclarations qui
s'inscrivent dans une double continuité
la première continuité c'est le naufrage
intellectuelle et républicains de jean
luc mélenchon qui est devenu la
caricature de lui-même et la deuxième
continuité c'est pousser jusqu'au bout
la logique de l'islamo gauchisme
quel est l'âge de logique de l'islamo
gauchisme c'est de dire en fait les
attentats antisémites commis par des
extrémistes islamistes c'est pas
vraiment ça c'est organisé parce que les
jets lévis a été très modérée moi ce que
j'ai entendu ce que des millions de
français entendu c'est ce sont des
attentats organisés par des gens
désignés par le système ça c'est très
pratique le système parce qu'on ne sait
qui c'est vrai que c'est mal écrit mais
c'est ça se dit ça c'est ça fourneaux
c'est ce qu'il dit kim notamment dont
l'extrait que nous avons motazé il ya
quelques instants exactement dans vos
amis disent exactement chose pareille
c'est quelque chose alisation qui ont un
esprit mentalisation c'est évidemment le
seul argument que vous pouvez présenter
vous ne pouvez pas dire le contraire
simplement je voudrais vous dire que
jean luc mélenchon ça fait longtemps
qu'il est complètement indigne de la
fonction qu'il brigue c'est le président
de la république
là il en est devenu totalement animé
t'emmène au vent bien je vous dis à vous
ce que j'ai dit alexis corbière que ray
kay mairie nous connaît bien il est
temps de vous débarrasser du ballon
parce que vous êtes une secte qui est
prisonnier des délires de cet homme tire
à vous êtes loin zemmour mais oui à tous
et on sait pas quoi répondre par de
zemmour mais moi je parle de mélenchon 0
il a rien à voir dans cette fois-ci tôt
demain mais attendez vous donc à ce qu'a
dit jean luc mélenchon est gravissime
parce que c'est de l'ultrabook l'autisme
rétabli laissé entendre des nouveautés
donc vous mais millions de français ont
eu un temps d'une jean luc mathieu dire
que nos attentes a absolument ploéven
n'aurait absolument pas son sol et
entendu des pleurs le seul instrument
que le système
grisé des actes envers ils repassent à
la hausse est le résultat des élections
et témoignerait pardon si ça leur part
de moi j'ai entendu la même chose
et franchement je trouve l'explication
de nous dire que c'était pas ça a ses
limites mais très bien attendez attendez
mais moi j'ai pardon je vais finir ma
france et j'ai envie de jouer pour
l'énerver mais j'ai une grosse joie donc
je vais finir ma phrase
et donc j'ai entendu les explications je
n'y crois pas vraiment mais même
admettons qu'il n'ait pas voulu dire ça
et qu'il est juste voulu parler de la
surmédiatisation pardonnez moi en 2004
le pardonner mois en demi lune en 2015
en 2012 il n'a absolument pas là qu'au
contraire tout le monde a fait attention
je me rappelle un grand édito de france
à beyrouth juste au même moment
expliquant que c'était horrible que
c'était la libération de la parole et
puis tout d'un coup quand il s'est avéré
que c'était meira plus personne et la
campagne de 2015 n'a absolument pas eu
lieu sur les attentats on avait une demi
on avait une 2250 mort est au contraire
parce qu'à ce moment-là macro était
quasiment mélenchonistes sur ces
questions culturelles identitaires
islamistes et cetera
ils voulaient pas le voir y a pas de
culture française c'était sa mine et si
vous voulez donc inapte la campagne de
au contraire nous n'en avons pas assez
parlé mais moi c'est une question vous
auriez vous ça veut dire quoi sur
médiatisé ça veut dire que quand on va
tuer des enfants juifs dans une école ça
c'est bon alors acadien ragga qu'on
aperçoit la maison je veux dire et à
l'instrumentalisation politique voulani
eric hautala
mais pas quelqu'un voulait qu'on ne sent
pas de 3s que j'ai dit que je n'allais
pas jouer alors on en parle tout le
contraire mais nous en parlons service
pierrick de l'autre et d'eric naulleau
laissez moi parler s'il voit ses
choristes
c'est que vous avez déclaré que vous
exécrez tout ce qui se rapporte à la
france en sont mises non c'est franchir
smith qui veut pas débattre avec moi en
plus dans cinq ans je l'avais déclaré
c'est sûr que je sois demande
aujourd'hui excuses vous répondre jean
luc mélenchon en 2015 était le soir même
sur un plateau dont tout le monde se
souvient je vous invite à aller voir la
vidéo
à côté d'edouard philippe d'ailleurs sur
un plateau où il était très clair sur
ces questions il a toujours été
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a fait
lever tout le monde à l'assemblée
nationale quand monsieur le
lieutenant-colonel arnaud beltrame s'est
sacrifié vous en rappelez quand même de
ces mots vous ne pouvez pas dire qu'il
n'a jamais été clair au contraire sur
ces sujets